>> Jon Parrish Peede:
I'm John Parrish Peede,
Chairman of the National
Endowment for the Humanities.
NEH is proud to sponsor this
year's Understanding Our
World stage.
Our agency is an
independent federal agency,
we were established in 1965.
We are part of LBJ's
great society legislation,
and we still continue
that charge today
with our sister agency the NEA.
The NEH supports museum
exhibitions, documentaries,
books that bring history,
literature, philosophy,
archaeology and the other
humanities fields to the public.
We also fund the preservation
of historic records,
collections and objects.
We sponsor educational
opportunities for K-12 teachers
and students in the humanities.
We also underwrite fundamental
research across the discipline
in the humanities that
includes university professors
or independent scholars.
And I must say what a special
panel this is, our next author
on this stage is a
celebrated journalist
and nonfiction author
Mark Bowden.
And what I would say
and I should say Mark will be
signing books from 12:30 to 1:30
and you know a good
bit about him
and our moderator
will tell you more.
Mark of course is a
distinguished journalist,
many of you read
him in the Atlantic.
And he's the author of 13
books on topics ranging
from the Iran hostage crisis
to the hunt for Pablo Escobar
to the killing of
Osama bin Laden.
And what I, and of course you
know him for Black Hawk Down
and we're here to talk
about his new book,
which we'll hear about today.
I might take a moment
to tell you something
that wouldn't be in the bio.
I had the honor and
pleasure when I worked
at the National Endowment for
the Arts from about 15 years ago
to about 7 or 8 years ago
to lead writing workshops
in Afghanistan, Kirgizstan
on a domestic basis.
And we wanted to get some
of our nation's veterans
who are writers, as well as
journalists to help troops talk
about their wartime
experiences, to teach them a bit
about the craft of writing, and
to help them if they wished to,
to unlock those cathartic
experiences.
And I must say that Mark
was a tireless part of that,
he was part of our
documentary Muse of Fire.
He is the father of
a veteran himself.
And when all the cameras went
off and there aren't a bunch
of people in the room
but there's just seven
or eight veterans on a base
in California who showed
up to hear a little bit
about him, maybe wanting
to meet a famous writer but
also quietly maybe wanting
to tell their story, this
gentleman gave of his time,
sacrificed his time, and
was really present to them.
So I think that should
be acknowledged here too.
[ Applause ]
So and of course, when you
look at who's praising his work
so many times is the military
veterans and he does indeed go
as a journalist directly
to the source.
And to talk a little
bit more about Hue 1968,
The Turning Point
of the American War
in Vietnam Mark is joined
by a remarkable person,
a remarkable journalist
to interview him.
Carlos Lozada is a
nonfiction book critic
for the Washington Post.
Carlos was a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize
in criticism in 2018.
So please join me
in welcoming them
and thanking them
for being here.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Lozada: So it
is a huge pleasure for me
to be sitting here with Mark.
I'll try not to be too much of
a fan boy and keep it together.
But I've been reading the
Atlantic for a long time
and of course we know him as
the author of landmark works
that you've read or seen
taken to the screen,
such as Black Hawk
Down, Killing Pablo,
and most recently Hue
1968, A Turning Point
in the American War in
Vietnam on one of the bloodiest
or perhaps the bloodiest
battle of the war.
Before we get into this I'll
just emphasize as was noted,
Mark will be signing
books from 12:30 to 1:30.
Also, will be plenty of
time for questions for you.
I have a few myself, but
then we'll turn it over.
And there's two mics here,
so you can come up
and ask questions.
And it's all being
recorded, so you know be
on your best behavior.
And I guess just to
start off very broadly,
aside from the appeal of a 50th
anniversary, why did you decide
to write about Vietnam now and
in particular about this battle?
>> Mark Bowden: Well the easy
answer to the question is
that my publisher ever
since Black Hawk Down was
such a success had been after
me to write another book
about a battle for
about 15 years,
and I kept telling him no.
But he urged this idea on me
and I started to read about it,
and learned a number of things.
I learned as you said that
it was easily the largest
and bloodiest single
battle fought in the war.
Very uncharacteristic of most
of the war fighting in Vietnam
and that it was fought
in this big city.
And I think that the
significance of the event,
which was I think the
largest single part
of the Tet Offensive gave me an
opportunity in a way to write
about the whole Vietnam War.
And you know my preferred
way of telling stories is not
to write sweeping histories,
but rather to find a
very dramatic moment.
And I think if you dig
deeply enough into an event
like the Battle of Hue you
see all the currents that were
in play in the war in Vietnam.
And it gives you a much
deeper understanding
of the whole event.
So I saw that it was, you know,
I think of more importance
that I understood, and also saw
that no one had really
done it well.
And the last thing is that
because Vietnam has opened
up so much in recent years it
afforded me the opportunity
that previous journalists
and historians didn't have,
which is to go to Vietnam
and to research there,
to tell the story
through the eyes
of both Americans
and Vietnamese.
So for all those reasons
I decided to do it.
>> Carlos Lozada: You know so
much of the great literature
of Vietnam and of America's
wars in general tend to focus
on the American side of the war,
how Americans were
marked by the experience.
You make an effort in this book
to chronicle the other
side of this war.
What specifically did you
learn about the Vietnamese
in the course of this reporting
and what were the challenges
of reporting and writing
that side of the story?
>> Mark Bowden: Well
I learned a lot,
I mean I think my understanding
of Vietnam was pretty
near the zero mark.
The time I spent in Vietnam
taught me a lot of history
and impressed me with the
determination of so many
of the Vietnamese
veterans I interviewed
to become an independent
country.
I don't think I met too many
doctrinaire communists I met
people who felt they
were fighting
for the freedom of
their country.
So I mean that impressed
me in that sense, you know,
they were perfectly decent noble
people doing what they thought
was the best for themselves
and for their country.
I learned that the Vietnamese
side which prevailed in the war
in the long run made a
lot of terrible mistakes
in the same way that America
made a lot of terrible mistakes.
In the Battle of Hue they
had incorrectly anticipated
that the people of the city
would rise up in support
when the troops came and
none of that happened.
And as a consequence, I think a
lot of the frustration and anger
that the Vietnamese troops had
was directed toward civilians.
So there were terrible
purges of civilians
which took place while the
city was in communist hands.
So all those things, you know,
it's always harder doing the
reporting in another country
where you don't speak
the language.
If you hire somebody who is
skilled which I was fortunate
to do, a fellow named Ho
Dang Hua [assumed spelling]
who also worked with
Ken Burns in his series
as a retired military
officer who knew his way
around the veterans'
organizations and government
in Hanoi, so Hua was
invaluable to me.
But the experience of
interviewing someone
in another language
is disconcerting
because you ask a question
and someone will give
you a 20-minute answer
and your interpreter will
give you a 30-second summary.
So, but I recorded all these
interviews and it wasn't
until I came home, I hired a
young woman at the University
of Delaware Xuyen Dinh who
translated, transcribed
and translated all
of those Vietnam.
>> Carlos Lozada: Verbatim?
>> Mark Bowden: Yes.
>> Carlos Lozada: Okay.
>> Mark Bowden: And so
sometimes you know it wasn't
until months later that I really
learned you know the details
of what I had been told.
And Xuyen was also, she's
from Ho Chi Minh City,
she was a terrific kind of
cultural counselor for me.
I mean she would explain
things that I didn't understand
and what people were telling
me, so she was invaluable.
And so like anything
else you know
if you don't know what you're
doing find people who do.
>> Carlos Lozada: So this
is a little shop talking
and navel-gazing
for journalists.
But how is the story of this
sort of fierce you know 24,
25-day battle told at the time?
What do you make of the,
you know, of the journalism
of that era and being
able to tell the story
that you've uncovered now?
>> Mark Bowden: Yeah.
I think you know is one
of the things that I wrote
about in the book and
I was so impressed
with how skillfully American
reporters who arrived,
who begin arriving very soon
after the battle began sized
up what was happening I think
with remarkable accuracy,
and put themselves at
great risk to do so.
So impressed with it and in
fact you know one of the things
that I make a point of in the
book is that the official count
of what was going
on in Hue was wrong
in just about every respect.
That the generals
and the White House
and the Pentagon were frankly
lying to the American people,
and it was only the reporters
and photographers on the ground
who were communicating to
American audiences the reality
of what was going on there.
So it was a striking example
to me of the importance
of an independent press.
>> Carlos Lozada: And
how quickly did that sort
of unofficial more
accurate version begin
to have a real political
impact back here?
You know, I mean
Johnson announced shortly
after Tet right that
he wasn't going to run.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada: And you
know Cronkite covered this.
You know how did that
filter back how quickly
and how accurately?
>> Mark Bowden: Well it had a
tremendous impact and I think
that the Johnson administration
and General Westmoreland had
set themselves up for a fall
by being overly optimistic
in their estimates
of what was happening
in Vietnam,
and how successful the
American effort had been.
I think the Tet Offensive
as a whole,
which was very widely reported
in some cases inaccurately
but for the most part I
think pretty on the money,
captured just the gap between
the official version of events
and what was going on.
I mean literally Walter Cronkite
flew to Hue in the middle
of this intense month-long
battle after having been told
by General Westmoreland
there was nothing going
on of any consequence in Hue.
And he lands in the middle
of a battle on a scale
of what he'd seen in World
War II in European cities.
So it was so striking
the difference
between the official narrative
and the unofficial one
that it fueled the
candidacy of Eugene McCarthy
who was challenging Johnson
for the Democratic nomination,
that brought Robert F.
Kennedy into the race.
Johnson decided just weeks
after this battle ended
not to seek another term.
And I think it really
moved the antiwar movement
in the United States from the
fringes to the mainstream.
I mean I think that the antiwar
movement was rooted prior
to the Tet Offensive in young
Americans who didn't want
to be drafted and who
didn't want to go fight.
So the movement was
on college campuses,
it was moral leaders right
like Martin Luther King Junior,
William Sloane Coffin who
were fairly predictable
antiwar voices.
I think what happened
after Tet is
that whole movement became much
more widespread and continued
to grow over the next
four or five years.
>> Carlos Lozada: Now a
cynic or a realistic can look
at that discrepancy
between the official version
of what's happening
on the ground
and say well they were lying.
But what do you think,
what's a fuller version
of what accounts for
that discrepancy?
Was it just people not
wanting to see what was
in front of their eyes?
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada: Was it
a long-running narrative
that they had trouble
moving away from?
What accounts for
that stark difference?
>> Mark Bowden: Well I can't
speak to the Vietnam War
as a whole, but I do know a
lot about the battle of Hue.
And I think it's fair to say
that the United States military
was shocked by the scale
and intensity of the Tet
Offensive, which frankly failed
in most places in south Vietnam.
It failed ultimately
in Hue depending
on how you measure
success and failure.
So I don't really fault General
Westmoreland and his staff
for being taken by surprise
because the enemy was very
skilled, very capable.
And I think anyone in a war
situation the enemy can get one
over on you.
Where I do fault them
and I fault Westmoreland
in particular is that
weeks after the city
of Hue had been taken by north
Vietnamese troops he continued
to deny reality.
And this was reality
being reported to him,
and you can go look
it up in his papers
in the Lyndon Johnson
Library in Austin
where he's getting
intelligence reports
which are extremely accurate.
He's getting first-hand reports
from young American Marines
and army officers who were in
the field, who are radioing back
that they're facing
overwhelming enemy forces.
Who were disbelieved and who
were repeatedly sent on missions
against overwhelming odds.
So many, it isn't just
misleading the American people
the decisions that were
being made in the first weeks
of that battle killed a lot
of young Americans foolishly.
Because I think that they could
have and should known better.
And I don't really know the
ultimate reason for it other
than I think when you're in
command you can be a victim
of a kind of a syndrome
where you believe you understand
the battlefield better
than anyone else.
And you like people
in many fields tend
to ignore information that
contradicts what you believe
to be true and stress
the information
that you think vindicates
your point of view.
I think you know that's
true in all walks of life,
but in a battle the
consequences are tragic.
>> Carlos Lozada: So
Westmoreland clearly emerges
as one of I won't say villain
but villainish [phonetic]
characters in the story?
And it reminded me a little bit
of H. R. McMaster's book,
Dereliction of Duty.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada: Which he
wrote, the former national --
he should not be known simply
as the former financial security
advisor to President Trump.
But he wrote a book some 20
years ago in which his focus was
on the joint chiefs
during Vietnam and the way
in which they either
weren't honest or forthcoming
with civilian leadership
or were manipulated
by the civilian leadership.
You know when you put
the joint chiefs together
with Westmoreland what picture
does it paint of the brass,
the military leadership at
the time during this war?
And do you think that's sort
of a fair characterization
writ large?
>> Mark Bowden: I think Vietnam
was a great learning experience
for our military.
I think that the United
States military was probably
at its high watermark
in terms of self-regard.
After World War II, after the
Korean War the United States
military was easily the
most powerful, best trained,
best equipped military
probably in history.
And I think that I read
a kind of arrogance
where you know the very idea
that a sort of ragtag bunch
of gorillas and a
poorly funded army
from Hanoi would somehow fight
the United States military
with its helicopters
and rockets, and tons
and tons of bombs and B-52s.
There was no force in
the world that was felt
to be the match for it.
But it turns out that in this
battlefield they were more
than holding their own.
And I think that
that came as a shock
to everyone except the
young military officers
who were facing it.
And a lot of the hostile
reporting about the war
in Vietnam which came from
young reporters who were going
out into the field actually came
from the people they
were interviewing,
young Marine captains who
were the ones being given the
responsibility to
carry out the mission.
And who were telling
a different story
than the 5 o'clock
follies back in the Saigon.
So I do think that many of
the people who I interviewed
in writing Hue were young
military officers at the time,
went on to long careers and
retired as brigadier generals,
four-star generals,
and you know are some
of the leaders of the military.
And I know they brought the
lessons that they learned
from Vietnam into our
military as a whole.
So I hope and I believe that
our military learned a lot
from that.
>> Carlos Lozada: Hoping you
can talk about those interviews.
You know you focus in this book,
I mean part of the great
strength of not just this book,
but your work in general is
you focus on the fighters,
focus on the sort of grunt
level heroism, and misdeeds
by men engaged in battle.
Fifty years later these
men are in their 70's.
How willing were they to talk
to you about this, to look back,
to really open up
about what happened?
>> Mark Bowden: Intensely
willing.
You know often people ask me how
did you get this person to talk
to you and the answer is
generally I showed up.
>> Carlos Lozada: Showed up.
>> Mark Bowden: I think in
fact, you know, as I look back,
particularly in the
early stages of reporting
where I literally knew
nothing I'm grateful
and wonderfully impressed
by the patience of men
like General Mike Downs, who
was in the middle of that fight,
a retired Marine Corps general
who very patiently you know
explained to me simple things
that you would think
anybody writing
about a battle ought
to know you know.
One by one by one.
So and that went down to
the individual privates,
the young sergeants who
were serving their four
or rather their one-year
tour over in Vietnam
and had these intense
and traumatic experiences
which have colored the
rest of their lives.
So they were for the most part
very willing to talk and also,
I find spoke with tremendous
candor about how they felt,
why they did what they did,
when they were frightened,
when they you know accidentally
did something right.
And about the people they
admired and the people
that they didn't admire.
So it's a remarkable experience
when you begin listening
and listening and listening,
and pulling together
all these accounts
into a kind of a mosaic.
I tell people that I view
a book like Hue as one
of those composite photographs
that are made up of thousands
of little individual photographs
that if you step back
from it looks like a portrait,
but when you look closely
it's actually thousands
of individual little pictures.
And that's what this book is,
it's a portrait of the battle
of Hue made up of literally
thousands of individual stories.
>> Carlos Lozada:
Let's look at one
of those pictures for a moment.
There's a Marine battalion
commander Ernie Cheatham
in this book, a former
NFL player.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada: Who
emerges, I mean he's almost
like an anti-Westmoreland
in terms of what you see
about leadership with him.
For those of you who haven't
had a chance to read it
yet can you tell us about Ernie?
>> Mark Bowden: Ernie.
>> Carlos Lozada:
And what you learned
about the war through his story?
>> Mark Bowden: Well Ernie
as you said was a battalion
commander and a couple
of his companies had been thrown
in piecemeal into the battle
of Hue before commanders
really understood the scale
of the enemy presence
in the city.
So Ernie who is a
gigantic man, he's actually
in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
as the highest-ranking
military officer who ever played
for the Steelers and
the Baltimore Colts.
He said at one time that he
was traded from the Colts
to the Steelers for a water
bucket and an unused helmet.
But he was given the assignment
or demanded to be sent to Hue
because so many of his
young troops were there.
So unlike I think
Westmoreland and some
of the higher command
whose error in judgment was
to believe they knew
more than the people
who were on the ground.
Ernie spent the whole night
before going into way Hue trying
to figure out how to
lead this counterattack,
to take the city back.
And he didn't know,
he started off
by realizing he didn't know
how many enemy were there,
he didn't know what kind
of weapons they had.
He didn't know where
they were in the city.
>> Carlos Lozada: This
is the night before?
>> Mark Bowden: The
night before.
>> Carlos Lozada: Okay.
>> Mark Bowden: And he is
telling himself what do I know.
I know that I'm going to
be fighting in a city,
and I know that my men have
never fought in a city before
and we don't have any idea
how to conduct tactics
in that kind of an environment.
So he literally sought out
old Marine Corps handbooks
on assaulting fortified
positions in urban fighting
from the Korean War and
spent the whole night boning
up on tactics for
assaulting a building
where the enemy was located.
And realized that his men
had inadequate weapons
because in one instance you know
in World War II American
soldiers carried bazookas
which were big heavy metal tubes
which fired a heavy
30-pound rocket
which would blow a
hole in a stone wall.
In Vietnam, they
had been upgraded
to these plastic tubes called
LAWs which were very much easier
to carry around, but
which didn't fire
as heavy a round
as the bazookas.
So the night before he goes
into Hue he rounds up as many
of these old heavier
weapons as he can find
and also puts his hands on all
of the large recoilless
rifles he can find
because he knows they're
going to need to blow holes
in the walls of these very
big stone buildings in Hue.
And also sought tear gas because
the way you assault a fortified
position is you poke holes
in it, you pump tear gas in
and hopefully the enemy clears
out before you send your
men across the street.
In the days before he got
there his men were being sent
across the street to
attack fortified positions
and just getting
chewed to pieces.
So you can understand
Mike Downs was one
of his company commanders
how thrilled they were
when Ernie showed up
with all those weapons
and with a more intelligent
way of going
about what they were
trying to do.
>> Carlos Lozada: That seems
insane that he, you know,
that the night before he'd be
like I realize I have
no idea how I'm going.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada:
To do this and.
>> Mark Bowden: That
was not the kind
of war we were fighting
in Vietnam.
I mean it was primarily
being fought in the mountains
and in the rice patties, and
American troops would often go
on long patrols and never see
the enemy until they got hit.
And they would be these
small hit-and-run attacks
so it was terribly
frustrating for American troops
to be fighting an enemy
that they rarely even saw.
And so suddenly they're
in a city
where there's 10,000 enemy
troops right in front of them,
and they don't have
the same numbers,
they don't have the
right kind of weapons.
And Ernie was smart
enough to realize that
and to take the appropriate
steps.
And I think he is what
enabled the Marine Corps
to turn the tables on
the Vietnamese there
in the first weeks
of the battle.
>> Carlos Lozada: And
that's leadership right,
that's him taking.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> Carlos Lozada:
Charge of the situation
by admitting what
he didn't know.
>> Mark Bowden: And for
one thing he was there
and he put himself right
in the middle of the fight.
And he was right alongside
his men, he trusted his men.
And if they told him that
there were enemy troops up on
that rooftop he didn't tell them
no there couldn't possibly be
troops there he believed them.
Karl Marlantes wrote this
wonderful review of Hue
for the Wall Street Journal
and Karl is a Vietnam veteran,
was a young officer in Vietnam.
And he told the story of a
friend of his in Vietnam who was
on a hilltop watching a caravan
of enemy trucks making its way
up the hill toward his
position, and he radioed back
to tell his commander
what he was seeing
and his commander said that's
not possible they don't have
any trucks.
He said well sir.
>> Carlos Lozada: Are you
going to believe me or?
>> Mark Bowden: He said you
are where you are and I am
where I am but where I
am I see Goddamn trucks.
So apparently it was not an
uncommon problem in Vietnam.
>> Carlos Lozada: And
what is striking to me
about this story is
to think even briefly
about Vietnam as an urban war.
>> Mark Bowden: Yeah.
>> Carlos Lozada: Right, because
it's not the way we have been
programmed or taught to think
about the war in this way.
We think of Baghdad, we think
of other conflict you know.
But that makes this battle
so unique and so distinct.
You read a lot about Vietnam
leading up to writing this book.
What for you are, you know,
did you decide really
are the greatest works
about this war Hue 1968,
notwithstanding for the moment?
>> Mark Bowden: Yeah.
I would say I think that David
Halberstam's book The Best
and The Brightest is
still a classic in terms
of understanding the people and
the thought processes that led
to our involvement in Vietnam.
I think that Neil Sheehan's
book A Bright Shining Lie is one
of the great books
about Vietnam.
I could if I had a chance
to think about this hard.
>> Carlos Lozada: Sorry.
>> Mark Bowden: Thought
of a couple more.
I read any number of
really terrific memoirs
by individual American
officers and soldiers.
There's one called The Lost
Battalion by Charles Krohn
which tells the story of
his air cavalry battalion,
which was basically on foot
because they didn't have
sufficient helicopters
in position who was ordered to
march his men a couple miles
down route 1 to the
walls of the city of Hue.
And told you know this would
be like a four-hour mission
and he lost half
of his battalion.
And they got pinned down
in the in the fields.
They had to cross enemy
lines in the darkness,
walking men holding on to the
man in front of them in order
to stay together as quietly as
possible to pull his men out.
Otherwise, I think they would've
been completely wiped out.
That story is I think one
of the most remarkable.
In my book the Battle of Hue
and I never would've been able
to tell it without Charles
Krohn's book The Lost Battalion.
>> Carlos Lozada: Great,
that's a great tip.
>> Mark Bowden: He's also
a really good writer.
There's a fellow Nichols Warr,
who's been a critic frankly
of my book which is fine,
but I thought he wrote a really
good account of his experience
as a young Marine officer in
what he called Phase Line Green,
that's another good one.
Well yeah, Dispatch is
Michael Herr's book.
I was thinking more
of the military.
>> Carlos Lozada: Right.
>> Mark Bowden: Accounts,
but Michael Herr's classic
Dispatch will be read
for a long time by people
who will have no interest
in Vietnam they'll read
it just for the writing.
>> Carlos Lozada: Last question
I'll ask you before we turn it
over to questions
from the audience.
People like me or critics are
always trying to find a thread
through the works of a writer
so then we can write
some big thoughtful piece
about how it all ties together.
You're here so I can just ask
you, you know when you look,
when you think about
your full body of work,
you know you focus a lot on
these on these moments right.
You know Black Hawk
Down is a moment.
You know Guests of the
Ayatollah is a moment.
Kuwait is a moment.
You know when you put all this
together what story do you think
you are telling in sort of your
overall project as a writer?
>> Mark Bowden: Well it's
not that I set out to do it,
but as I look back
I'm old enough I have
to look back over
a body of work.
I think I've struggled
a lot with trying
to understand America's
role in the world.
And I think you know we are
at a unique point in history
where our country is
the most, is the richest
and most powerful
nation in the world.
We are capable of
projecting power anywhere
in the world we want to.
And we've made some wonderful
uses of that opportunity
and we've made some
tragic uses of that.
We've engendered in some cases
irrational hatreds you know
from people around the world.
But I think that struggle
of figuring out how
to be an American
in the 20th century,
in the 21st century is something
that I find deeply fascinating.
And that's why I'm always
so interested in traveling
to these parts of the world
where the United States has
projected military force
and trying to understand
those stories through the eyes
of the people who live there
and through their culture,
through their history, and how
they see the United States.
And I think you know,
I hope that that will help all
Americans have a more nuanced
understanding of what it means
to be a good citizen
of the world.
>> Carlos Lozada:
Thank you, yeah.
[ Applause ]
We have time for questions so
you can line up at the mics
and please let's make
them questions rather
than comments or speeches.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
After going to Vietnam
and interviewing
so many Vietnamese what's the
story that America yet has heard
about them during that time
or any thoughts around that?
>> Mark Bowden: I'm sorry
I had a hard time hearing.
>> Oh, I'm sorry.
After going to Vietnam
and interviewing
so many Vietnamese what's
the story America still needs
to hear about them
during that time?
>> Mark Bowden: That's
a good question.
You know I think and I said
a little of this earlier
that it's always enlightening to
see the humanity in the enemy.
And you know one
story typical of many,
many of these young Americans
who were fighting
were 18, 19 years old.
I met this young
woman who was fighting
for the Vietcong and she was 18.
Her whole family had been
fighting against the French
and then against the
Japanese, and then now
against the Americans.
And I think Cha-Ti Mong
[assumed spelling] is her name.
She had a very moving story,
she was ultimately wounded
fighting for the city.
So to me this was a thoroughly
decent young woman who went
through tremendous sacrifices,
was badly wounded fighting
for what she believed
was the right thing.
And even though I make a point
of writing how the excesses
of the forces that she was
fighting for some of them tragic
and horrible don't necessarily
define the individuals
who were trying to
do the right thing.
I think the bottom line is
that what we need to understand
about the Vietnamese people
in the 1960's was most
of them I think were
fighting for independence.
>> Thank you.
>> Carlos Lozada: Sir.
>> My question is about
the competence and effort
of the American soldier
in that battle.
You know we're familiar with
stories of you know a lot
of soldiers wanted to get out
of Vietnam, they didn't want
to be there, they didn't
trust their leaders.
But when the battles actually
happened it seems like they gave
at their best, perhaps because
their lives were at stake.
But what was your
perception of the quality
of the American soldier and
the lower-level officers
in this battle?
>> Mark Bowden: I can only
use the word extraordinary.
These were young men who were
in a terrifying position.
Outgunned at least
in the beginning
of the battle and outnumbered.
They to a man told me that
they figured they'd be killed
or badly wounded because many
of the people I interviewed
were wounded,
they're survivors obviously,
but they were evacuated
before the battle was over.
And I think their ability
to continue attacking,
to continue doing what
they were ordered to do
under such hellish
circumstances I don't know
that I would have the courage
or the wherewithal to do it.
And they also were very smart.
They didn't know how to fight
in a city in the beginning
but they figured out tactics and
they figured on-the-fly a lot
of things that kept them alive,
and that kept them going.
And I think when you
dig into the details
of what I'm talking about,
like learning exactly
where to place a
round on a house
to collapse the entire
house they learned how
to do things like that.
How to assault windows you
know by shooting at the edges
of the windows instead of
shooting through the windows.
Very detailed little tricks
that they picked up very quickly
as you will when your life is
in the balance was nothing
short of extraordinary.
So I have tremendous
admiration for their skill
and for their courage.
>> Thank you.
Having written about
and learned so much
about Vietnam I was wondering
if you had any comments
about Senator McCain, his
experiences there if you know
about them and him having
been a prisoner of war,
and also his views on torture?
>> Mark Bowden: Yeah,
well you know I think most
of us now know the
story of John McCain.
It's hard to imagine
a more stirring
and heroic individual
caught up in that conflict.
I think drawn for all
the best reasons to fight
for his country,
being used in a way
which was I think
misguided and foolish.
Just you know we were
sending aviators over Hanoi
to bomb things like
wooden bridges
that could be rebuilt in days.
We were exposing
aviators like John McCain
to tremendous hazards
for very little gain,
and he paid an extraordinarily
high price for his patriotism
and valor and then
suffered horribly
at the hands of his captors.
I think much to his credit
he emerged from that I think
with a moral conviction
against abusing prisoners
and against abusing inmates.
And he adhered to that through
years when many in his party,
many who were, you would have
expected him to be allied
to he stuck to his guns.
And so I admired
him as an individual
and I don't think I've
read too many stories
of individual courage that match
John McCain's story in Vietnam.
>> You mentioned the
invincibility of the US military
at this time versus the
ragtag army Vietnam,
but you also mentioned that they
were fighting for independence.
And if their cause was basically
just we were the bad guys even
though we had overwhelming
military force.
What role did all this play
in the fact that we lost
against a ragtag army?
>> Mark Bowden: Well I think
that you know if I had to point
to the basic flaw in America's
effort in Vietnam it was
that we did not have any
legitimate indigenous allies
of any consequence.
We were fighting on behalf
of a makeshift South
Vietnamese government
that wasn't particularly
Democratic,
that had very little
broad popular support.
And so no matter how
many bombs we dropped
and no matter how
skilled our soldiers were
and brave they were
fighting a population.
Those who were not shooting at
them were sheltering the people
who were shooting at
them and feeding them.
I think that you,
we underestimated
as a country the commitment
of the Vietnamese people.
And I do think that
you know the principles
that the United States
was fighting
for were the right ones.
And I think Vietnam frankly
has paid a heavy price
over the last half-century for
the victory of communist forces.
They are still today primarily
an authoritarian country,
people don't have
the kind of freedoms
that we have in this country.
They've loosened up the economy
so that people could
now own property
and start their own businesses.
So they've begun to enjoy a
higher level of prosperity,
but I think they lost a great
deal when they sacrificed
in the name of independence
their own liberty.
So I think that the United
States very frequently
when we send troops
overseas we do
so with an incomplete
understanding of the region,
of the country where
we're sending our troops.
And I think that in many cases
dooms us to, if not to fail
to end up and mired for
years and years and years
without being able
to make progress.
>> And this is actually like
sort of a follow-up question
to that gentleman's question.
And I haven't read your book
yet so I don't know
how much you focus
on the South Vietnamese army.
But in terms of you're saying we
didn't have indigenous allies,
what was your take on the pretty
obvious lack of effectiveness
of the South Vietnamese army and
why it proved to be ineffective?
And not just in 1968, but
very obviously in 1975?
>> Mark Bowden: I'm sorry I'm
having a hard time hearing
because of the acoustics
in here.
But my evaluation of?
>> Well the South
Vietnamese army.
You were saying that we
didn't have indigenous allies.
>> Mark Bowden: Right.
>> But we were technically
allies of the South Vietnamese.
>> Mark Bowden: Sure, yeah.
>> What's your take on their
lack of effectiveness both
in 68, but also in 75?
>> Mark Bowden: Yeah, I mean
an army is a huge thing.
So I have no doubt and I
met some extremely capable
and valorous former
South Vietnamese officers
and soldiers who
fought very hard.
I think the facts are that
they were few and far between,
that there was tremendous
corruption in that army.
Officers were given command
because they knew somebody
or they paid off somebody.
They had no appetite for
actually leading men,
for doing things like
Ernie Cheatham was doing.
And I think that the inadequacy
of those forces was exposed
over time so that by 1975 once
the United States withdrew there
was no chance that the South
Vietnamese army was going
to withstand the North
Vietnamese and the Vietcong.
>> Carlos Lozada: I think
we have time unfortunately
for just one more
quick question.
>> I better make it a good one.
So the research in
Hue was really amazing
and I'm interested in
your writing process.
Like once you actually sit
down to write do you write
for a certain word count or
a certain amount of time,
and what are some of
the obstacles you face
to actually get to
the finish line?
>> Mark Bowden: Well
that's a good question.
You know the one thing that I
know most is the writing process
so I feel comfortable.
But I, you know, I always begin
reporting stories, like spending
like 99% of my time reading,
traveling, interviewing,
researching, and maybe 1% of
my time jotting down ideas
to myself of in this case just
trying to develop an overview
of what happened
during this battle.
At some point in that process it
segues to about 50% reporting,
50% writing where
I know enough now
to begin constructing
a narrative,
but I'm still doing
a lot of reporting.
And at the very end of the
process I'm 99% reporting
but I'm still running around
trying to get one last interview
or one more detail about
this thing or the other.
When I'm writing full-time
I write in the mornings,
early in the morning
until about noon.
And then probably the most
that I can sit and write is
like four hours at a time.
And I think after that I'm
not really writing very well
which makes for a nice
lifestyle you know.
You write in the morning and
then you goof off all afternoon.
But when I'm engaged in a story
like this it's all consuming,
I literally dream
about it at night.
And if I encounter narrative
problems trying to figure
out how to segue from one
thing to the other or how
to organize material in a
particular part of the story,
that seem you know impossible
to me I'll sleep on it and wake
up in the morning and
the answer is there.
So I really have a belief that
your mind continues to work
on things even when
you're not conscious of it.
So that's pretty much my process
and you know a book like this,
this book was five, six
years in the making.
So that reporting piece of it
was pretty much all consuming
for three years or more, and
then the last, the writing part
of it was like to
two years or more
of pretty much you know
getting up in the morning
and writing every day.
>> Great, thank.
>> Mark Bowden: You're welcome.
>> Carlos Lozada:
Mark, thank you for.
>> Mark Bowden: You're welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Lozada:
We're glad you got
through that writing process.